d'abord d'entre eux trois
maintenant pour cette mission il nous
faut le meilleur parmi les meilleurs
la citée de briques mansion tellement
dangereuse qu'on adule emmuré personne
n'entre leur chef détient le maire et la
moitié de la ville en otage ont commencé
en chaire à 30 millions vous vous sentez
d'attac
je suis toujours d'attaqué et là bas
vous avez un contact quelqu'un qui
connaît bien bricman chef un ex taulard
pour m'aider je sais comment nous faire
entrer nous c'est ça il ya la première
aux castes une flamme dans le dos equit
barre si je voulais tuer ce sera la fête
du sport
ça va être une partie de plaisir
qu'est ce qu'il faut ici
tu devrais apprendre à te battre devrait
apprendre à terre
on a un nouveau shérif en ville et tu
vas plus dormir tranquille
c'est naze comme idée ou pas ma thèse
l'ascenseur on nettoie c'est mieux que
c'est ce que dit le rapport
le dérouillée sans se faire démonter